[Music]
welcome back Haneda University a Tampa
visiting professor assistant professor
Kenneth story is in hot water tonight
after tweeting a very hateful message to
Texans as hurricane Harvey was pounding
the Gulf Coast over the weekend he wrote
quote I don't believe in Instant Karma
but this kind of feels like it for Texas
now hopefully this will help them
realize the GOP doesn't care about them
ironically he is now facing his own
Instant Karma
according to reports he was fired by the
University at Tampa and they have
condemned his remarks story later
apologized on Twitter writing quote I
deeply regret a statement that I posted
yesterday and never meant to wish
ill-will upon any group I hope all
affected by Harvey recover quickly oh
that's so sincere tonight it appears mr.
story is deleted his Twitter account
good idea joining us with reaction Fox
News contributor Mercedes schlopp New
York State Senator how did this ever
happen Democrat Brian Benjamin how did
that ever happen
the people are oh my god they love me
all right congratulations I give you a
full credit you went out you campaign
hard and I wish you I hope you serve
your constituents well it's about a
sewer in DC it's worse up in Albany just
in case you want enough that's two real
problems how many of your leaders up
there got indicted recently over the
years since I've been elected no one I
know I hate to share it so no one yet
you know we've seen a lot of hate we've
seen a lot of attacks tonight and I want
you as a Democrat to say this is wrong
and it's outrageous I just want
something Democrat to say because I
don't hear it enough this is wrong and
it's outrageous I mean there's no doubt
about it appeal but I think the
environment is also outrageous and I
think some of the comments that the
president makes leads to this kind of
environment and I think that's what's on
for tea blaming that well you're blaming
the president for what other people say
that's right no no I'm not believing the
principle other people say I'm believing
the present for what the president says
and I think okay fair enough he is our
president
yeah ed you got I'll give you
Charlottesville is a great example bring
the ladies in 1991 he condemned David
Duke races and white supremacy did it
all throughout the 90s into 2000 and all
through the election he condemned it on
the Saturday the Monday the Tuesday the
Wednesday and
people still attacked him so I don't
think he can win well he can't win and I
think the media is constantly trying to
see if the the president's going to have
the next his next misstep for example so
when you look at this Texas situation
where the president went down to Texas
has had a very strong coordinated
efforts between the cabinet agencies and
local and state counterparts and it's
basically sending a very strong message
of unity of saying we're here for you
Texas we want to make sure that you know
we come together as Americans and yet
you have those on the Left basically
saying that his remarks are not
empathetic I mean that's just simply
ridiculous and so I find it to be
difficult to watch how the how the
Liberals are just still trying to
nitpick and find any single mistake that
the president you know would make in a
case like this and it's incredibly
infuriating because what we've seen
today is we're clearly has been a cutter
in chief